openly openly you'll never be him
pebble you're a pebble you're a little
stone you're a skimming thing
monday fun day let's get it let's go oh
yeah we're in sync today in it standard
[ __ ] sake
we're here guys
and uh yeah it's booming we're feng shui
the vibes are flowing we're feeling good
um
and yeah man it's going to be a good
time it's going to be a good time before
before we get into anything too serious
guys anything too funny let's just
prepare ourselves make sure you're ready
for the longevity of the s g cult okay
you can't just dip your toe in every now
and again you need the longevity the
consistency and the routine of good
vibes and dopamine in your system and
the only way to do that guys is head on
over to patreon.com forward slash shits
and gigs it's going to cost you three
pound a month 10p a day you need to run
the peter sng
and get three years worth of content
unfiltered on set unfiltered uncensored
unedited content over on patreon uh join
the booming community that is over there
guys um
and get an extra episode every thursday
so you need to join the cult twice a
week now we're up in the indoctrinations
okay that was the word i couldn't say
ages ago indoctrinate yeah we're up in
the indoctrinations guys
uh we're reading the scripture we're
preparing the log cabin and the white
robes and yeezys have been ordered right
different sizes
yeah bag of sizes guys
um so head on over to patreon.com
forward to our shits and gigs and uh
join the cult for real for real yeah um
also guys if you are listening to us on
the
audio app such as spotify apple podcast
amazon music audible whatever you want
to listen to your podcast guys make sure
you please please please please please
give your boys a nice rating it really
does help spread the holy word
um and help the giggles come
worldwide
right um
and if you are watching on youtube guys
please subscribe to the channel we're a
mission 1 million subs we're far away
from that now so in order to get that
tell a friend to tell a friend to tell a
friend to like the video if they liked
the video chirp sitting in the comments
as always and click the subscribe button
and the notification bell so you know
when we're posting hot and fast guys um
and without any further ado
my comrade
my
big tt bredrin
my succulent lip
that
liaison
file of ways
is gonna hit us with ig questions
at the beginning of an episode
game-changing id questions today are
split into two
parts to gender roles if you will yeah
and we're going to laugh equally at each
yes okay so our first half of ig
questions guys special treat for you
today at the beginning of our episode
final earthquakes please kill em facts
so
this week it wasn't really a question it
was just like a mr a little miss so
everyone's been seeing it going around
this has been a massive trend these past
couple weeks little miss
xyz or mr x y and z
obviously i thought i'd ask the fandom
for their best ones and here we are so
i'm gonna do the misters first and
ladies don't worry your time will come
at the end of the episode so yeah we'll
clap your cheeks at the end okay
be patient with us yeah be patient let's
get this one out of the way and then
we'll head on to you after yeah so cool
boom mister
so prep just bear in
mind a lot of the misters were written
by women and of course they weren't
yeah
just fyi
so one chick wrote
mr [ __ ] stains
oh my word what was the first one mr
[ __ ] stands the [ __ ] stains mister when
are you coming to see me
i hold my hands up i've done it we've
all done that before good times from
mr give me a second chance
no my knees give me a second chance
please
mr secret cross dresser
there's venom in these i bet the i bet
the gold ones are nicer than this
there's venom behind these i remember
i'm separating them so now all right
let's see let's see this one she put a
twist on it oh no he put twist on it she
said she calls me mr pebble because i'll
never be the rock
openly openly you'll never be him
pebble you're a pebble you're a little
stone you're a skimming thing
i used to do that for jokes
mr it's not going to suck itself
mr sending me a pic with the pre-eyes
send me a pic
guilty is charged
guilty's charge
someone a little something mister i
won't show my friends
it's funny how they're just back-to-back
bro that's the same
he's
mister you make me come quick
we're just talking about that on patreon
what happens to the best of us
i'm guilty for this one mister let's go
with the flow
oh yeah i'm guilty yeah
that's me to a t mister i'm married but
it's not serious
that's funny
mister she's just my baby mum we only
live together for the kids
rawr
fam
mandem will lie
viciously through the skin of their
teeth
for a little taste of time yeah yeah
for a sprinkle of time sprinkler pus
they will say anything
say anything
god mister i'm different i promise oh no
mr can't pay his bills but can pay his
plug
okay say less
mr size doesn't matter
who's that mister
um fam if i was ever put in a position
where i actually had to say
both sides doesn't matter really matter
in this situation ah
yeah that's stab me yeah kill me mr
whose [ __ ] is this
mr mr [ __ ]
where's all this man slipping and
sliding and not even hitting the target
in my formative years mr justin
let me just feel it let's feel
right it say
i'm not even going to [ __ ] you anyway
well i don't want to do that i'm tired
man just
i just want to feel something just the
tip
yeah
oh
mister i'm gonna marry you one day you
know
said that mister
mister i'll never leave my wife but i
want you
that's a bold mister
that's a boat
i just fly it
oh sweating
i was sweating bro i love so hard
that laugh made you poor that's jokes
that's jokes
oh [ __ ]
well played g that pic i already know
that picture's gonna be a yellow don
draper
oh i'll never leave my wife but i want
you
that works eight times out of ten for
him
facts that works eight times out of ten
facts
mr where's my hug been there i've always
everyone said that yeah rex
mister i don't go down on girls cause of
allah
oh jesus christ that's funny
mister i've never felt like this before
i've said this one last i missed her
what you saying b
that w y s yeah
fam this one
mr passenger side of his best friend's
right
trying to hold out me
now
and last but not least mr compulsive
liar oh rags
[ __ ] yeah now yeah that was just a
little taste mr passenger side of his
best friend's ride
that's funny that is actually hilarious
that was jokes that was like he started
off off with a bang
you've got um you've got the ass off
when you know
so where you got signed before that it's
not under my [ __ ] yeah it's like uh
it's just it's a it's a new ish one
because it's a story time
we ain't had a story time in a while
it's a fan submitted story time okay so
let me just uh dig it up quickly right
saying what you said to me in the
patreon episode this one's a long one
okay so buckle up i'm going to try and
set the scene as best as i can right
story time
the fan edition right
okay
so i started talking to this guy
and things were moving pretty fast but
overall okay
after a couple of weeks he sent me a
screenshot of this really sweet written
note that he had put in his apple notes
um on his phone yeah he said he wrote it
about me
but the note had another girl's name on
it okay
okay okay fam
when i asked him about it he said it was
his cousin and he originally sent it to
her to comfort her because their
grandfather had recently passed and she
was very close to him
i was a little confused because fam i
was a little confused because why does a
message to his cousin
match a message he would send to me
bro
but i let it go your business
fast forward two weeks i look up his
socials and on instagram the same girl's
name is in his bio with that padlock
emoji
bro i confronted him about and said
uh either you lie to me or you're
[ __ ] your cousin both are gonna piss
me off
so which one is it
jokes
[ __ ] funny he proceeded to say
that uh she was his ex and he lied to me
because of his childhood trauma
still confused about how those two
correlate i asked what this trauma was
yeah
um
that's what the trauma was he proceeded
to tell me he this entire story about
how when he was in the seventh grade he
was talking to this young girl on kick
messenger oh wow
they decided to send pictures back and
forth his mom saw the messages on his
phone
and realized that the texts were coming
from an adult
based on the wording of the messages the
cops got involved two weeks later
the cops
with no further
cop the cops were no no further in
finding the man stroke woman that was
allegedly messaging him
he was home alone when a grown man
knocked on his door
the man busted into his house and beat
and raped him
so of course
it is hard for me to believe this story
but at the same time i'd feel like a
[ __ ] if it was true and i'd called him
a liar
before i could respond though he told me
he was going to off himself and blocked
me on everything
i was stunned what what the [ __ ] do i do
now yeah 15 minutes later his older
brother messaged me on instagram and is
asking me what is wrong with his brother
yeah he then asked me if i would
facetime chat with him i did and i
proceeded to tell him the entire story
um
his brother told me
that it was all a lie
and then also said that his brother has
done this to countless other girls oh my
god
bro
end of story oh
my goodness mr compulsive liar mr
compulsive liar indeed bro
so
yeah
yeah to recap please
she is chatting to a brayer and things
are moving fast but she likes it
out of nowhere
he sent her a handwritten note
of some love poem thing whatever
and it's a next thing's name in it sauce
when she goes on his instagram she sees
the same name with the padlock emoji
which is such a
wasteman emoji
i can't stand it sass
so when she says is this your girl or
your cousin fam either way you're lying
either way you're a liar tell me the
truth man said it's my ex-girl
but she's still in my bio i lied to you
about it because of my childhood trauma
what's the childhood trauma fam
long story short
in year seven i was messaging a thing
turns out that thing was a breath
that bruh found out where i lived
broke in my yard while i was all alone
beat me the [ __ ] up and had his way with
me
that's why i had to lie to you
they don't even
it's irrelevant
and before she had a chance to say
anything he said i'm going to kill
myself by the way
by the way before you can respond i'm
offering myself yeah i'm going to kill
myself now
15 minutes later his brother
trusted a girl and says why is my
brother acting like this
she facetimed me explains the whole
thing and the brother called his larry
said oh he's lying
he's lying my little brother is a
[ __ ] little liar yeah my brother's a
liar he's done this and he's countless
days doing this
i can imagine a facetime homeboy's in
the corner just crying
and his brother's his brother's fed the
[ __ ] up bro this reminds me of a story
uh this reminds me of a cheetah's
episode that i watched i was in this is
when i was in i already know this is
funny and cheers episode
not cheetah sorry catfish catfish
episode sorry catfish episode i was in
malta just when i was still on holiday
um
one of the nights i didn't go out i just
put the tv on a generic tv and uh i
think it was tlc they were showing um
what did i say catfish catfish i was
gonna say cheetahs again it was showing
catfish and bro there was this chick oh
there was this chick that was
finessing so many people but she
finessed this one bread all right and
they fell in love
of course fell in love he loved her yeah
but the thing about him was that like
obviously he was genuine and he had lost
his
pops earlier in i think the year in like
earlier in his life and he lost his mum
that year due to cancer or something
couldn't remember he was pretty young he
would have he was probably like 18 or
19. oh really yeah he had his own place
and it was like saving to go to like
medical school oh something
was ambitious and he was a church girl
he was like
he wants his life to be better fam he i
can already tell he's a church guy
you in those situations you are either
turning to god or satan or say this one
of them
he had to turn to the your father so
he was he was an avid church girl right
yeah and
this chick when they were talking was
helping him with his confidence and like
just helping him with through life
um she would they would read bible
scriptures together whatever blah blah
but she didn't live where he lived so he
wanted to go see her but he was figuring
out how
things weren't adding up and then i
think he said he got a random text one
day from an unknown number saying let's
call her caitlyn for example caitlyn
isn't who she says she is
just out of blue
that you know there was where you tried
to bill it and it doesn't go through
yeah yeah yeah there's reverse numbers
where you can't call back oh some
bernadine oh my god isn't who she says
she is
that would send me rattled him
these men got involved
so long story short they flew to where
her apparent known location was it was
in some boarded up yard
so as soon as he opened the door no the
the person that sent the text was the
one that came out the caitlyn anderson
who said who she said she was the one
that came out here and said oh yeah my
sister's in it was her sister now
she's she's been doing this to countless
men
shut up countless men walked in
when i say to you bretta
catfish
disgusting hat
fish
i don't know which one she was the cat
or the fish swear bro
catfish yuck and she was like she was as
soon as she went to me and she was
shaking of course shaking hugging it
like i'm so sorry i just
as soon as i start i can't stop i i need
i need attention because everyone used
to bully me while i was in school i
would they used to call me so ugly and
like this is the only way i can get
attention and and once i start it's it's
hard for me to stop and you know and
then one of the one of the brothers like
do you think you're ever going to stop
saying
i don't i don't think so i don't think
so no no bro
all she does
to day in day out week in week out is
stay in a room and catfish people online
that's her only form of
endorphin
yeah yeah yeah because she's in real
life she knows she's not cleaning yeah
these man want fake caitlyn they want
they want her they want her bro it was
unreal jesus so that's what that
reminded me of
jesus that's exactly what that reminded
me of she was shaking of course i
watched the cat
i watched the catfish a few months ago
because they've got they've got a
chicken there now as well isn't it that
follows she runs with nev um
no idea is it neve
i don't know any other names
okay
the homeboy who refuses to shave his
neck bid
me the main don it infuriates me
anyway um
so
um
what was it
they
patented there was some lesbian woman
who's chatting to one baddie
for time loves her
he's in love with her and every time
they're gonna go link yeah satin comes
up
like the day she's flying out comes up
and she's like this is annoying me and
we talk on the phone we've done this
we've done that like i love her i
[ __ ] love her i need her i need her
in my life i [ __ ] need her i'm
willing to fly out she won't let me fly
out i'm sick of it
so
something like the yeah was in a next
city
um
the catfish chick was in the next city
so
the hope girl
is called a red because i think her name
is actually red because she keeps
wearing red snapbacks all the time it
was infuriating um
red was like oh she's in like a city
that's like not too far from here i want
to go linker so mess it up i'm a
surprise thing yeah i know yeah league
up shoes are out holiday i want to meet
you want to do this and obviously caught
up in the thing says yeah fly out we'll
do a ting so she's like gang
neve comes out
um
doing that because i think her brother
or her sister shouted me and said fam
come and chat to red yeah because she
can't see sense
the whole family has turned against her
now because she's not seeing sense
she's not saying [ __ ] sense this is a
catfish
she refuses to believe it
and is like it was dread as well because
it was like the thing that she's talking
to is a baddie and the sister's trying
to say they're nice and red is butters
in like with all due respect she's
butters she couldn't she couldn't
pattern a thing like this
so
she was trying to say to her sister fam
i'm not you're my sister i love you but
come on what are we doing here you're
not yeah yeah and then obviously you're
just jealous and all this stuff jealous
i'm not jealous i'm not gay
yeah i'm not gay and i'm not jealous i'm
being honest with blood and i love you
you need to see sex
so neve rolled through did some reverse
imaging thing that he always does
um and finds the real thing gets her on
facetime and makes red sit down and chat
to her
and she's like for just for her to tell
her yeah i've never met you
we've never spoken i'm sorry
i'm sorry about whoever's doing this to
you but we've never met and i do not
love you
i'm [ __ ] married
i'm married with kids
found bread was distraught
distraught
and then obviously
they managed to get the catfish out to
meet them in some parks somewhere the
catfish yeah
had a defense mechanism oh is it she
sent for them as soon she came out of
the car on smoke
her and the new co-host were about to
square up she came out of the car and so
much vim okay bro okay i was just like
yeah i did it and what tell me satin
tell me something all square up oh shut
the [ __ ] up first she came up with so
much smoke never had to simmer down she
didn't want it she did
never because both the female coast and
red were were arched up yeah yeah it was
about to pop off
all three of them were about to just
start laying bangs into each other it
was wild that's jokes and then once
you'd simmered down she was like oh i'm
[ __ ] sorry
but still with the vip yeah you're
[ __ ] sorry right
i'm all [ __ ] sorry yeah i do love you
all right
i love you
how many times have you done this and he
was like how many times have you done
this she was like she said it's like
ridiculous like a very specific number
like 314.
314.
straight from the deadpan he said how
long have you been doing this she's uh
since i was 13.
he he didn't know what to believe
he's been thinking i've been doing this
show for seven years and i've never
heard anything like this
it was atrocious wow
yeah i hate catfish but sometimes it
they're locked
it's juicy trashy um oh i've got a show
recommendation for you let's answer this
question first what's the thing we never
helped her out yet who what oh
what
i forgot about the story i know you did
i was encapsulated
raw
yeah
well there's nothing to advise to give
her it's wrapped i think oh yeah she did
what was the final thing the final thing
was the brother just said
he's nuts oh yeah he does all the time
story time yeah
yeah fair enough yeah yeah yeah
that's that's unfortunate they had to go
through that darling but yeah that's a
song for you also yeah word of advice
you're an idiot
when man said
it's my cousin
her name my cousin's thing
you're sitting there talking about i was
a little bit confused because xyz
shut up
he's
a liar you chose to believe i mean you
chose to continue yeah
these are facts it's literally facts
it's literally facts it's literally
facts because there's a choice you made
that's immediate red flag immediate red
flag in red he didn't even take the time
to remove the name from the bio
or even under in the middle yeah the
original notes yeah
i if i was him i would have
lied on the spot and said oh that's just
an alias i used when i was writing it as
opposed to saying that's my cut you know
this is just this is the first draft
this is the first draft yeah because i
thought i can't i can't just put it when
my phone gets hacked i can't let the
real name be in there exactly yeah
that's easy that's easy it's an easy lie
do you know what i mean yeah that's my
cousin yeah i'd have to spin it on some
jokey joke thing
yeah actually i'd i'd double down into
it so she thinks i'm winding her up like
this is a long play yeah yeah yeah in
terms of like she'll be like oh who the
[ __ ] is sophie and i'm like who sophie
there's a name in there that says sophie
and i'll be like i'll send this emoji
she'll be like i sent this emoji
i should be like are you [ __ ] serious
are you actually taking a piss out at me
right now and i'm like oh
sorry that's my main [ __ ]
and she was thinking he must be winding
me up yeah yeah because he can't he
can't be doing this but really i'm
telling the truth the whole time
sophie literally is my main [ __ ]
sorry you're not sorry yeah
i'm out recycling loveless the game is
the game tis
cheers but yeah um show recommendation
oh my god yeah show recommendation yeah
it's called bird box on apple
have you started i've not started it but
i knew
eventually either you were gonna watch
it and talk about it or i was going to
watch it today anyway i've seen
the trailer and i've seen
reviews about it it's based on a true
story as well so where yeah i cannot
wait to watch it james i can't wait to
watch it bro if i was you i'm not gonna
lie leave it a couple weeks
oh yeah because it's still every friday
and it'll wherever fam i didn't even
know that i just started it because the
way my apple tv set up yeah it just says
epis when i when i find a show if i type
in bird box yeah
on my laptop click it yeah it doesn't
give me a breakdown of how many episodes
it is it just says play episode one in
this big blue button i play it the
player opens i watch it and then once
that's done it says play episode two
yeah it doesn't tell me there's only
four so i banged it out
only to find out that four was the last
one that's out and then i'm waiting on a
friday ting now if i knew it was a
friday thing the whole time i never
would have started it yeah
oh
oh yeah
gripping yeah oh i can imagine it's a
slow starter but you enjoy the slowness
i've read the premise so i i know the
gist of what these shows yeah yeah yeah
but yeah i'm very much very much looking
forward to it bro the actor who plays
the crazy person the bread with
high-pitched voice yes i saw him in the
trailer i was thinking i already know
you're acting your ass off i know you're
acting your ass off because
he was talking like this bro
bro
he's crazy
he's crazy bro so just to recap for the
people i haven't seen or the um the
people that haven't heard about it i'm
pretty sure the premise is a guy has to
make another prisoner confess about a
crime he committed so basically this is
the thing like that the premise is is
that it follows a guy called larry hall
who
is what they call they class as a serial
confessor
so he keeps confessing to crimes that he
quote unquote didn't commit
and through this process of him being a
serial confessor everyone thinks he just
lies and all this stuff yeah and he's
got like learning disabilities and all
this stuff and like um
basically um there is
um obviously a class of uh police
officers and detectives that
know he did it and this whole run around
play dumb thing it's just a long play
they know he [ __ ] did it okay and
they managed to get him to sign a
confession one time so he signed a
confession because
basically this won't spoil it um
they managed to get him to sign a
confession because
in one chat he had
in one interview he's having the police
he let slip and a close detail oh that
was in his yeah in his
fake confession but he's in public to
the people there was there was data in
there that was not [ __ ] public okay
so he was like
he ain't fake confessing brother
no one knows that detail he [ __ ] did
it okay so they had him up and they said
sign his confession big man if you're
really confessing sign the confession so
he was like all right i'll sign the
confession signed it expecting
everything to go the same way it always
goes
locked him up but then on a time frame
because basically he's got put an appeal
through yeah and there's other crimes
that he's confessed to that they know
for a fact he didn't do because they've
caught the guy who did it oh yeah so
there's other crimes he's confessed to
that they know he didn't do so the more
that happens they might exonerate him
yeah so they're on a very s small time
period now but he's gonna get exonerated
and if he walks he's [ __ ] walking
so while he's in there they need to get
another basically they've finessed
another prisoner and said if you can go
into this but he's in a low security
prison he's just a drug dealer but he he
can chirps
he can chirp okay he can chirps the
pants off anyone okay he's confident and
chirpsy and makes you feel good about
yourself okay okay yeah yeah yeah he's
he's a nice guy builds you up to take it
all he yeah he builds you up to take it
all literally what he does okay he makes
you feel amazing about yourself so
therefore i know that so they tell him
and said if you're willing he's in for
ten years they basically say if you're
willing to transfer to this maximum
security prison befriend larry
and get him to confess and tell us where
the bodies are buried if you can do that
we can defeat his appeal keep him in
here and we'll let you run free
you ain't doing 10 years
and how long has madman been in there so
far the the brother that wants to
transfer not the money seven months
he's been in pen for seven months he
hates it too yeah yeah he's in a low
level thing and he has to transfer it to
him yeah he fam
he's
terrified
i would beat him he's
fantastic i would be get
to
slice boiler alert i couldn't even get
that
and as he's at just about to leave the
van he says
stop
he says stop it i can't do it take me
back
he said i'm [ __ ] scared take me back
and then like stop so i was like you
have to do it [ __ ] up the back
he said fam i wasn't thinking please
take me back
i'm so scared
fam and i was thinking facts
i would be terrified
and his dad who's been in there was his
dad um was an ex-cop yeah when he told
his dad about the deal that they're
gonna tell me uh they told me if they
transferred to this prison they're gonna
let me out and he said because he stands
as an ex-cop they said transfer you
where
do you sit because the prison the
maximum physical springfield they're
gonna transfer to springfield he said
don't do it
don't do it
firm is that said don't you dare
springfield springfield you're not going
you won't last a day now
he said for the love of god jimmy do not
go there
it was too much we had i was in there
gasping bro
that's [ __ ] hilarious [ __ ] it no
don't go
please it's that's crying fam crying is
shaking so you can't take that deal oh
my god only to ring him one day to find
out that he's not there
he took the deal behind his back dad
rings him to find out he's not [ __ ]
there his dad loses it
and and they do back stories
back stories okay oh
okay
the psychology behind it as well because
in order to really befriend javi he
needs to believe he needs harry to
believe he's they're one and the same
yeah so harry can start confessing larry
sorry larry can start confessing to [ __ ]
yeah yeah so fam when larry asks him
questions
sometimes jimmy's like what the [ __ ] did
you just say yeah
what the [ __ ] did you just say but he
has to play along
he has to play along and the details are
gory
and then he asks him personal question
but he has to put himself in the
mentality
and start saying stuff and some of it's
kind of true he has to really get deep
into his psyche
and also start confessing [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
layers
oh [ __ ] layers to this show okay
and vex there's only four episodes yeah
apple tv
i'm telling you oh it really doesn't
matter
people are sleeping on apple tv [ __ ]
gang it's a show
yes yes it's a [ __ ] show i'm signing
it tonight all right
when you catch up the good thing the
episodes are an hour as well oh but i
love that
i love that
they fly as long as they are they
[ __ ] fly by because they're juicy bro
it's good show gang it's a good show
yeah i'm here for it
it's a good show that's that's the
production company from um do you
remember the end of sea i think season
one is season two of um
rick and morty that he used to come on
what did he say it's a good show oh yeah
i remember i remember i remember i
remember i remember i remember said i
was like rough
um what have i been watching i watched
three movies yesterday back-to-back
jesus what did you watch the grey man
which i told you about
oh was there yet that you were talking
to me about the james bonya yeah yeah
she's piff she's delicious
i know i think her name is like anna
diamox or something like that yeah she's
in war dogs as well isn't she i'm not
seeing more dogs oh okay cool cool um
wait i watched the the gray man action
[ __ ] i saw the trailer yesterday i saw
the trailer yesterday i was like oh
watch it ryan
gosling trained for this movie
i've been seeing petitions for him to be
james bond so i know he did a good job
in the game he trained for it bro say
less so yeah that's a really really
really good action chris evans up in
there
yeah really good movie so i watched that
i watched knives out as well that's a
good movie um murder mystery again chris
evans in it anna diameter's in it as
well
um and coincidentally james bond yeah
yeah um and i watched
there's a movie called the father
which
um wasn't it anthony hopkins
i watched it last night i think it came
out last year
yeah yeah yeah i see the trailer for
that as well
psychological brother when i say anthony
is his name's actually anthony in the
movie as well he's losing his mind
james really he's losing his mind no i
couldn't he's in a premise right
he's in a flat he thinks he's in his own
flat in london this is in that it's in
english when i say english i mean like
london english like britain britain
english sorry so he's in his own flat
in london
um and
he's
he's he lives with his he lives with his
daughter and his daughter
this vlad his daughter comes quite often
because she works for her blood but she
has to go and go and come go and come
but he's old so he wants she wants
someone to take care of him
like a stadium nurse or yeah a nurse
kind of thing but every single time they
hire someone he loses his mind and they
leave so there's no one to look after
him so he's now she's now saying
i need to
find someone because i'm moving to
france because i found a man and i love
him
i want to dip i don't want to deal with
this i don't want to deal with this yeah
he's like what the [ __ ] blah blah blah
the next day
her name's uh her name i think is anna
yeah the daughter or amy one of them
i think it's anna so anna comes through
again but he's seeing someone completely
different not his daughter it's like he
looks something like anna that's not you
this is not anna and there's another
brother in the yard who's anna's husband
but he's like
i thought you were divorced but bro when
i
he goes into so many different states of
men mental state it's like
i'm even struggling to follow it oh jake
he's losing his mind every day
every day because the more i say it's
going to spoil it yeah yeah
there are twists in this book oh vam i
couldn't handle it you sounds like a
shutter island it's one of those ones
because you watch the movie through the
lens of anthony oh okay yeah yeah so
everything crazy that we're seeing is
through anthony's eyes oh no and it's
when i say it's insane like if you
actually feel like you're anthony and
i'm losing my mind fam yeah as soon as
i'm lucid kill me
as soon as i snap out of it oh kill me
bro there's a point where he can't take
it anymore euthanize me bro he can't
take it because he knows someone's lying
to him and he doesn't know who he is
family walks in his room and slams the
door he's shaking him no no no no no
yeah there are times where
this the scenes somewhat repeat
themselves because he's seen it happen
before
but then it happens again like two days
later but he doesn't know why has this
happened and why have i seen this before
but oh bro it's it's mad and then when
it the finale the ending is just
bro it's mad it's a good movie auntie
hopkins doesn't really miss it's a good
movie
really good movie so definitely watch it
it's called the father i'm gonna watch
it i'm gonna watch grey man first and
then i'm to watch it as a movie sales
movie action-packed movie it looked it
the trailer which went on and on and on
packed movies yeah sailor celeste
gosling is a g in that movie all right
bet he needed a comeback he's a g yeah
he's been sleeping for a minute he
needed a comeback what is up guys brief
little break to pay some bills um and to
throw
some love over to the guys and girls at
man skate right guys so we've said it
before we're going to say it again
manscaped performance package 4.0
guys it's quite everything you need to
prepare for the summer board we're deep
in summer now it's hot hot time to
prepare
get ready to get your titty out okay get
the breasts out
guys get that snail trail trimmed up
get the pubes clean
and with that we're gonna need
even more effort
nose and hair nose and hair nose and ear
hair
so we need the weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer along with the
lawnmower 4.0
trimmer
on top of that guys i'm wearing them
right now performance boxer briefs oh my
travel bag we've got the cr really yeah
i actually um
it's soft it's soft what can we say
uh the crop preserver ball deodorant and
crop reviver toner guys
on top of that we've got a couple
goodies uh with the travel bag it's it's
it's banging okay um
but what we really need to focus on is
the lawnmower 4.0 which we've spoken
about before which has got cutting edge
ceramic blade to reduce grooming
accidents thanks to the advanced skin
safe technology the lawma 4.0 as a 7 000
rpm motor uh most mine can't even count
that high brother so that's how you know
this is
up yeah it's up up
can engage a travel lock essential
and give you the ability to turn the 4
000
k led spotlight on and off when needed
for a more precise shave guys and did i
mention it's waterproof so now we're at
the beach the lake the shower we can
just keep escaping on the go we're
escaping on the go guys
all right it's smooth summer and we're
escaping on the go so guys if you want
to jump on with the
gazillion men that have already jumped
in your boys included you need to head
on over to mansgate.com and use the code
sng sierra november golf that's
manscape.com code is sng it's your
november goal and you're going to get
yourself 20 off and free shipping
worldwide guys i'm not going to say it
again get on over there and um because
because
get on over and because
all right guys back to the episode thank
you okay um so you got a scenario for me
uh yeah right so someone sent this to
our instagram it's um this someone sent
it to the shade room so it's a shade
room um
scenario
my husband suggested that we should be
more stable financially before we make
babies and i agree with him
six years down the line i started
complaining to him that it's high time
we welcome our babies
he said just a little patience so
instead of arguing with him i stopped
using my pills
along the line i noticed and complained
bitterly that i would i want to destroy
his long-term plan for us
he said the money in the joint account
is for our babies
that we will soon get to his target
a few weeks after on my on my way from
his office or from the office sorry i
visited my in-laws to give some to give
them some food stuff on the way out my
husband's younger sister decided to see
me off to the car
and told me that we needed to talk we
needed to talk but not here and i must
not tell my brother
what my sister-in-law told me was like a
movie to me that my husband has three
children with his childhood lover and
they are relocating out of the country
soon
she said she was so sorry that she can't
hide it anymore because of the kindness
towards the family after hearing
everything i prayed for death but it
never came
i decided to take a day off from work to
search the house if i could find any
documents to confirm what she told me
my people it is true
i found all the documents i needed in
the store not i found the documents i
needed in the store not in our room oh
my god i took it all i took all of it
international passports with visas even
the money in brackets she wrote my money
now he's looking for it and he can't ask
me
at this stage i am tired i don't even
know what to do next i need your advice
to do um to know what to do next tear
the visas and passports and raise
absolute hell in this house that you can
never forget
or the joint account do i empty that
first
so backstory fam
yes please so let me give you a recap
again
so there's a there's a husband and wife
right
husband is saying
give us some time let's get let me get
my financials in order then we can have
utes it's been six years
she's saying when are we having utes man
saying not right now keep waiting keep
waiting so she stops taking the pill
he notices he's like ra
are you doing this she's like alright
say no more i'm gonna go back on the
pill yada yada
a few weeks later now she goes to
the husband's family's home to drop a
few things
the husband said so let's say i'm the
husband my sister comes to speak to my
wife saying takes her outside takes her
outside because you can't say in front
of the family
babes
listen
you're you're a nice person you're a
lovely person so i can't keep this in
anymore but my brother's a [ __ ]
little like he's got three he's got
three utes with his childhood lover and
they're moving to france looking to move
to france
no way she would drop to her fram
what do you mean all of them my husband
as well
they're looking to move to paris
tomorrow
i had to tell you
i'm so sorry
she's like
bet there let me go find some evidence
before i run her muck in this [ __ ]
cool so she starts doing some digging
starts doing some digging she prays for
death it doesn't come and she's like
[ __ ] it let me take a day off work pray
for death bro she's she's given up her
life for him wow pray for that she's
like [ __ ] it let me take a day off work
let me do some digging she doesn't find
anything in the off in the yacht she
finds something in the office
all the paperwork all the documents so
she's now asking do i [ __ ] tear up
the visas and the passport or yank out
all the p from the the joint account
because at the end of the day there's
nothing he can do or say
without exposing himself
because he knows science are wrong now
and he can't expose himself what should
she do first well what should she do
period what she yeah she's asking what
should i do first first that's what she
enter the account or burn the visas to
the ground yeah which should you do
first fam
i mean
right
that's evil
not her i'm saying he's he's evil pure
evil evil
how did he how did he even have the
chest to tell his family by the way
i'm leaving my wife and me and the kids
and my ex are all moving to france
do not tell my wife [ __ ] knows like uh
bro
bro my son or my brother could never
tell me that oh wow what do you mean
exactly when are you going to tell her
i'm not we're just leaving bro and
leaving that all on me
don't tell anyone
no oh it's a fist fight it's a fist
fighter who raised you bro that's
insanity um but
right let me put myself in the
this is right
this is a declaration of her safety now
okay because let me put myself in his
shoes okay
if she's gonna pick one um don't pick
firsts
pick one
and i would suggest
burn the visas okay because i can get
new visas yeah you empty that account
as safety
you empty that account
because i know what she's gonna say but
he did
you empty that account shut the [ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ] up
that i've been saving for six years
someone's going to check it
someone's going to jail yeah it might be
me it might be you yeah
bro
six years of savings and you're just
gonna drain it
bro i know i'm the devil yeah but don't
test me
i know i've done nothing but wrong
yeah yeah
don't test me don't put me in a position
where i've got nothing left to lose yeah
fact because i can get new visas so i'll
just be vexed because you've still got
my money at ransom yeah so i'm gonna i'm
gonna do this play plating for as long
as long as it takes to get what i need
but you touch that money
i swear to god
[ __ ] fun yeah
yeah finding out the truth is going to
be the least of your worries if you [ __ ]
with my money
wow you adopted that wrong i have a
dungeon roll now let me take my crazy
hat off
you need to get him you need a
restraining order a man because he's
tapped
six
years
how has he finessed this
bro there's so many people he needs to
speak to what does his ex and kids think
is going on where's he been what's
happening
vam
fam what's what is going on compulsive
liar mr composer yeah
certain people in this world
just can't stop lying
you know
it's literally what's that what's the
thing where you go on um
uh
a rabbit hole you just can't [ __ ]
stop yeah you need to lie and deeper and
deeper one light has to cover the other
to the other it's like bro there's no
end game here bro there is no end game
what is the point that's i'm sure i know
the point but yeah yeah [ __ ] me i'm sure
one of the traits of like an actual
psychopath or a sociopath
is uh
the fact that they are convinced
that people will never pick up on their
lives
they're convinced they're smarter and
better than everyone and their lies are
just impenetrable
crazy he's crazy he's crazy he is crazy
because i don't see how
i couldn't live out
such a huge life for such a long period
of time
i would i would probably stomach it for
i would say a couple months not even not
to talk of a year let them six years i
wouldn't be able to balance the fact
that i'm i've got three kids with my
childhood lover and we know we're
dipping soon we know we're dipping
country but i'm still here doing house
playing up a house with a woman that
wants my utes
and i've lied to her
to keep my real family safe and i've
told my immediate family don't tell a
single soul
because i'll burn everyone to the ground
firm to keep my real family safe
do you know what i mean
it's all you're only one man bro you're
only you're going to end up with split
personality disorder yeah because yeah
you're going to lose your mind you're
wearing hats you're going to lose your
[ __ ] mind he has lost his mind it's
not worth it he bought tickets and visas
to france
it's just not what
it's not worth it
i'm and the most annoying thing is like
when you find when let's say i'm the
brother i find out that she's found out
i'm like who the [ __ ] told you
who the [ __ ] told you he needs to nut up
and be like i know you know yeah just at
breakfast
just in the morning yeah she cuts one
little dirty look and he kisses you i
know you [ __ ] no
[ __ ] no
tell me [ __ ] told you right now tell
me who told you and tell me what [ __ ]
visas are tell me what enough visa is
tell me about you tell me you [ __ ]
touch my money if you've touched my
money fam if you've dead
spend money penny in that account my
kids money
just throw that in there yeah my kids
money i won't be held accountable
what happens next i won't be held
accountable oh he's crazy as soon as she
hears the words my kids might she'll
laugh oh she'll lose it
do not test a woman's scorn
you can make threats and promises all
you want do not test her she would lose
it whose kids
that yeah who's kid yeah yeah you can't
poke a mother bear fam you can't poke
her that account is drained
that account is don't touch my kid's
money
she you would literally hear snap and
you won't know where it came from
fam her pupils would just dilate styling
it's just like
swear down and that's what you hear oh
okay
and she'll just like you just see high
heels clicking out the door scurry up
and you don't know what's coming next
do not test a woman's scornfup bro
especially when it comes to kids
i've been baking you for kids for six
years and you have the cheek to say to
me don't touch my kids money
yeah it's long for him i love how he
makes [ __ ]
i love it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's done he's
done for yeah yeah [ __ ] so he can be as
crazy as he wants yeah but you pull that
yeah that [ __ ] on a woman
she'll finish you bro it's long man
she'll finish you that's a
predicament for all parties
every single party involved is a
predicament yeah she needs to
to
burn the visas and just change locations
she's yeah she can't stay in that area
anymore yeah because it will only bring
her heart
you know and she's in danger
heartache and she's in danger she is in
danger so burn the visas get off your
chest and leave leave take the money and
leave yeah yeah
yeah read the [ __ ] locate change your
name that's um that's a next thing wow
that was a crazy scenario that was a
crazy scenario
and man said
he's trying to keep his real family safe
back
thanks bro
that's too funny bro
[ __ ] honest
oh right what you got for me man
oh so there's another thing i've got to
show you or got to read out for you it's
a it's another this is another story
type right this is another long one to
bear with
taiwanese woman discovers her son's
kindergarten classmate
is the daughter of her husband and his
mistress
while taking her son to school the woman
ran into the mistress and the little
girl and immediately recognized an
uncanny resemblance between her between
her husband sorry and the girl
she later realized that the little girl
was the daughter of her husband and his
former mistress
according to her post the woman found
out about her husband's affair five
years ago when she was pregnant with
their son
the husband and his mistress begged for
forgiveness and vowed to cut ties for
from each other
after this a quote after five years
she still lives in the same town as me
and she gave birth to a girl the woman
wrote
when confronting her husband he denied
the claims and even pushed the woman to
the ground ra
indeed his wife indeed i asked him
what's going on today i asked him if the
child was his and he didn't reply
i asked him if he was in contact with
his mistress secretly and he even called
me crazy wow not answering me
that's my name to
answer me i'm not justifying your silly
little questions with an answer you're
crazy [ __ ]
man i pushed her to the ground and just
said
shut up
i'm not gonna ask you again
shut up
oh what is wrong with mandem bro what is
wrong with these compulsive liars
they're insane
the woman also revealed that she was six
months pregnant with her second child
and stated in an update post that she
moved out and planned to live with the
with her parents until she gave birth
i don't care i don't care that i'm
pregnant for more than six months
my heart is suddenly cold and it turns
out that all of this has been a lie
lying to me for about five years when i
think about it they've been sneaking
around all the time and i'm going to
break down
she also stated that her husband stopped
by her parents home to beg for
forgiveness however she's not ready to
give to forgive him
whether i forgive him or not i shall
wait and see the woman wrote
can you imagine brother
what are the odds to me for that odds
are probably high
how
what are the odds that she took one look
at this little girl and said
[ __ ] it now you look like my husband a
five-year-old girl
how uncanny can this resemblance be it
must have been
spitz bro
spitting image
and then her brain was like this
[ __ ] cheated on me five years
ago i just remembered oh right she was
like i know who you are
she said to my man look
i dropped homeboy at nursery today and i
saw you that looks just
like you then i did some digging and
guess who her mom is that little slaggy
were [ __ ] in five years [ __ ] that you
were banging behind my back five years
ago and how old is this you i'm so sorry
if my maths is correct
she's exactly the age that she would
have been
if she was conceived then facts
and
she is in your son's class she's in your
son's class did you know about this
man just ignores the question says
you're actually nuts you're actually
shut up you're nuts
a man pushed her to the ground she's six
months pregnant
put paws on her yo man are crazy james
man are crazy and when they get caught
in a lie man are crazy
when they're successful in their life
they feel like they're god facts they
feel like that god when they get caught
they're so offended because it's like
how dare you think you can talk to me do
you know who i am yeah that's why he's
probably going through his hair yeah do
you actually know who the [ __ ] i am
nah brav
man
he has no shame zero she said are you
still [ __ ] her
are you still lincoln are you spending
time with us you and i said stop asking
me silly little questions
you're crazy you're nuts bruv you're
crazy i'm
i'm obviously i'm here aren't i i'm here
every night every night where else would
i be
i had to beg to get you back do you
understand that do you know what i did
to get you yeah i had to beg and plead
to get you back it's been five years i
think we're past this yeah i don't you
think we're past this
five years later you really want to dig
this back up we're tired we're expecting
there's another one on the way you can't
be doing this now we've got amazing
family that's continually growing and
you want to chat about some ho from five
years ago she's irrelevant
she's irrelevant she's a nobody stop it
i don't know who this you you're talking
about is but you've got nothing to do
with me i'm damn sure well she doesn't
look like me yeah i know she doesn't
you're chatting oh [ __ ] you just want to
make peace yeah fit that's what you
definitely saw her he'd be like oh i
know what's happened i'll actually know
what's happened
porting you saw her you got triggered
yeah and you just came up with this
little all of a sudden just because you
saw her and you got fixed you want to
make out that you look like me don't
test me again facts don't test me again
it's not my fault you bumped into the
mistress i used to bang five yeah yeah
maybe you should do your due diligence
and see who's in our son's class because
i mean making money
i'm not in making money forever for us
so
so don't ask me
don't you ever
do you ever insinuate
i'm cheating on you
[ __ ]
yo
[ __ ] sake
oh that was funny oh [ __ ] [ __ ] that was
funny oh [ __ ] sake
oh my goodness yo
[ __ ] man goodness right let me um take a
breather and then we've got
the second half the second half of ig
yeah yeah [ __ ] that oh jesus that's
hilarious
that is hilarious all right i'm ready to
go ah give me a sec god damn it man
we've got problems but we do
we do
right guys girls i know you've been
waiting for this so obviously the
beginning episode we did mr
end of the episode we're going to run it
with lil miss
right
facts
little miss doesn't shut the [ __ ] up
facts that's that's base level base
level facts little miss irritable bowel
syndrome oh no
just pooping
pooping and [ __ ]
yuck
little miss social media stalker oh
fam
that's all
that's funny little miss i need some
wine to take the edge off
little miss it's five o'clock somewhere
facts
little miss i'm sorry our star signs
ain't compatible oh
literally go to hell
this could either be a
or a
okay little miss i'm pregnant oh
oh
fam
little miss i'm pregnant
says she's three months pregnant and
she's keeping it
it could be joyous or heartache one of
them little miss my diet starts on my
day
lil miss doesn't take her own advice oh
yep yep yep
yep
little miss i swear i was on birth
control
i may have forgot just one day
ah little miss would you love me if i
was still a worm
ah lil miss sorry i fell asleep
cheat just say you don't like me yeah
right it will make me feel better yeah
oh right exactly little miss i can drive
i just don't have my license
yeah right scorsy can be when i was 18
yeah and all these september birthday
hoes were not 18 17.
they're all taking their lessons they
were stealing their parents cars oh is
it this whole i can drive i just haven't
passed yet
stealing oh [ __ ] it was constant
oh my god
little miss do i have mug written on my
forehead
apparently yes you do right
little miss man talk to you about our
lord and savior jesus christ
little miss sage and crystals oh wow bro
right this one back to back back to back
to back little miss i'm on my period
little miss you're gonna hate me
little miss come inside me
i've had all three i've had all three
sarah
little that third little miss come
inside me needs to die
come inside bam
stop split immediately you want to grip
some cheeks together stop saying that
because i can't control it anymore i'll
get you pregnant
i'm gonna put a baby in there and i'm
gonna be living about it
little miss oh lil miss do you think
she's pretty
women are such
[ __ ] [ __ ]
bitter [ __ ]
oh
little missy looks better in person
lil miss helps her friends cheat
rags
right game
lil mish choke me oh dude
oh dear
go on google neil miss must have been
that other [ __ ]
oh i hate that [ __ ] little miss
eavesdrops and hurts her own feelings
yo
yo
that's funny
lil missed dating a man twice her age
yep calm back again calm
little miss bites her boyfriend
little miss is your wife home
oh
we love to hate that little miss
we hate to love you
and last but not least little
misrestraining order
rags
jesus yeah
yeah oh that was it for the middle
that was fam that mr and miss
on a back to back yeah was one of my
all-encompassing favorites gang
beginning and end game i really really
enjoyed this episode for a lot of for a
multitude of reasons yes we went on
story
that was all over the shop that was a
lot of fun yeah guys i hope you enjoyed
it as well uh that was
easily top 10 in my first all-time
episode it was funny because i i
thoroughly enjoyed that um so guys as
always head on over to patreon.com and
catch us on thursday it's going to cost
you three pound a month a day um
and uh as always guys love love